hey clatter fans josh mokuba here with
what is possibly the most controversial
video you watch all this Christmas
season because I know there are a lot of
people out there that consider die hard
to not be a Christmas movie my wife
being culprit a number one I've gotten
tweets about it I've gotten Instagram
messages about it I've gotten messages
on my home answering machine that's
right I still have a landline because I
still consider the greatest year in the
history of Christmas movies to be 1988
that is the year the movie die hard was
released in theaters now not only is die
hard a Christmas movie but die hard is
the hands-down greatest Christmas movie
of all time it is the quintessential
Christmas movie and if you don't think
it's a Christmas movie I'm here to give
you the top 6 reasons that's right
6 reasons why die hard is the greatest
Christmas movie of all time
now you're plaster yourself Josh bronze
do 5 or 10 that's what all the other
lists do well I'm not like everybody
else ok first of all I couldn't think of
10 and I didn't want to make a 30 minute
video and second 5 was just not enough
so I went with 6 sue me yippee-ki-yay
mother here we go the sixth reason why
die hard is the greatest Christmas movie
of all time is the music now every great
Christmas music has amazing music love
actually has that Mariah Carey song
holiday in has white Christmas a bunch
of the other ones have amazing Christmas
music and die hard is no exception the
die hard score is an action score set to
Handel's Messiah not only one of the
greatest songs ever made but considered
the greatest Christmas symphonic ballad
of all time did I read that in the book
no I just made it up on this video go
with me you've got sleigh bells and just
about every part of the chorus Bruce
Willis at the beginning of the movie is
whistling a Christmas song in an
elevator Hans Gruber is humming a
Christmas song and as sergeant al Powell
leaves the 7-eleven he is singing a
Christmas song add all of that to when
the world is exploded when our guy
lights up Christmas and Hollis in his
limousine and the movie ends with let it
snow that is in fact a Christmas movie
you don't put Christmas songs not in a
Christmas movie do you put Easter songs
in a Thanksgiving movie no you know why
because there's no such thing as
Easter movie and there's really no such
thing as a Thanksgiving movie except for
train planes trains and automobiles my
fifth reason is the stereotypical
Christmas character now everybody knows
that in every movie there are the
stereotypical Christmas characters and
die hard we've all got them
you've got your Santa Claus in John
McClane you got your mrs. Claus in Holly
Gennaro aka hauling McClane aka miss
Gennaro
you've got your Grinch in Hans Gruber
you've got your Rudolph in first-time
limo driver aka the sleigh in argyle as
Rudolph you have your group of
mischievious elves and Carl Theo and
company you have your hit Santa's Little
Helper in sergeant al Powell you have
your idiot Christmas uncle and deputy
chief Dewayne T Robinson you of course
have your sacrificial lamb and Joseph
Takagi
r.i.p you have your friends who are
really into the Christmas spirit but
eventually died in an explosion in a
helicopter crash r.i.p Special Agent
Johnson and agent Johnson and of course
you have that pesky reporter who's not
sure if Santa Claus is real but it
really wants to get to the bottom of
things in Richard Thornberg one quick
note the Homer kill doesn't exactly
sanction die hard you can go ahead and
boycott if you want the four threes and
die hard is the greatest Christmas movie
of all time is the miracles now
everybody says it's a Christmas miracle
it's been uttered so many times in
movies TV songs and in Mark Wahlberg's
career it's too hard to keep track and
that little girl from It's a Wonderful
Life can take her little angel given the
Bell and angel's wings and really take
that back to the line at JC Penney while
she's waiting for Santa Claus because
die hard has the most Christmas miracles
of any Christmas movie ever shall we get
started
name one movie that has more Christmas
miracles than dire John McClane takes
out 15 terrorists he falls down an
elevator shaft he crawls through a
ventilation system he runs around the
entire building with no shoes on he
takes a fire hose wraps it around his
body
repels down a building through a glass
window while the thing almost drags him
out of here I mean the genius alone of
thinking to use a fire hose and also
rappelling down the building is a
Christmas miracle in itself now what
they say is that Santa Claus will do
anything in order to get the toys to the
kids and let's just say this John
McClane will do anything to save the
Nakatomi Plaza get his wife back and
Hans Grover Six Feet Under it's a
Christmas miracle your Gd right it is
Philadelphia may have rocky but Century
City has John Ginn McClane the third
reason in my extremely loud and
incredible list here of why die hard is
the greatest Christmas movie of all time
is the obsession though everybody knows
that people get obsessed with the
perfect gift the perfect time of year
the perfect way to give that gift
getting your kids a tickle-me-elmo how
are you gonna get your kids a
tickle-me-elmo the perfect drink the
perfect outfit the perfect everything
and die hard is no exception
everybody is obsessed with something
should we go down the wormhole down the
wormhole we go Hans Gruber is obsessed
with taking 640 million dollars in
negotiable bearer bonds from the NACA
Tomek corporation John McClane is
obsessed with killing Hans Gruber Carl
then becomes obsessed with killing John
McClane after John McClane kills his
brother Hans Gruber then becomes
obsessed with John McClane as John
McClane has his detonators
Theo becomes obsessed with a miracle
needed to take out all of the locks in
order to get into the vault with the
negotiable bearer bonds sergeant al
Powell is obsessed with getting back on
the street even though he shot a kid
Dwayne T Robinson is obsessed with
impressing the FBI agents the FBI agents
are obsessed with power
Hans Griffith then becomes obsessed with
Holly as he's trying to not only take
his 640 million negotiated negotiable
bearer bonds but he's also obsessed with
taking John McClane's wife in order to
get back at John McClane John McClane
then becomes obsessed with killing Hans
Gruber all well Hans Gruber has become
obsessed we're taking the skin off of
John McClane's feet all in all at the
end John McClane wins because his
obsession with bringing back Christmas
and the Christmas to all in the Nakatomi
Plaza winds as the obsession of Hans
Gruber does with killing everybody else
becomes is downfall and see the second
reason why I heart is the greatest
Christmas movie of all time is the
ambiance everybody knows a great
Christmas movie is all about the
ambience a roaring fire snowfall some
eggnog the warmth of kith and kin and
die hard is no exception what better way
to start a fire than sending c4 down an
elevator staff strapped to an office
chair with a 1988 IBM desktop if that
doesn't start a fire I don't know what
will and it keeps the entire building
warm ok who needs a fireplace
light it up and yes la may not be
the quintessential place for a Christmas
movie as it hasn't snowed here since
1962 and the only time it ever got any
kind of accumulation was in 1949 but
when you blow up a building full of
paper and that paper snows down on you
like snow in Antarctica it is not only
white you could Pesce Li cut you but it
covers the ground just the same let it
snow let it snow let it snow John
McClane you are our Santa Claus
and finally the number one reason and
top reason in my mind of why die hard is
in fact a Christmas movie is the white
elephant gift exchange now we've all
been to a white elephant party and
really if you go to a Christmas party
and they don't have one it's really kind
of a letdown but if you've ever looked
at die hard in terms of a white elephant
gift exchange party you're really
looking at it like a Christmas movie
first the white elephant gift exchange
is all about taking and giving gifts
first hans gruber wants to steal the 640
million dollars in the ghoshal bearer
bonds
now John McClane steals those bearer
bonds back only to have to give them
back to the Nakatomi corporation a full
white elephant now the secondary white
elephant gift exchange really starts
when John McClane steals a machine gun
from Carl's brother who he kills falling
down a flight of stairs and snapping his
neck he also steals the detonators from
Marco which really in senses Hans and
because it's not Hans has turned so far
yet in the elephant gift exchange
Hans sends Carl who's in front of him in
the gift exchange to steal the
detonators back Hans then steals Holly
Gennaro McClane aka John McClane's wife
which really wasn't his turn to steal
her now coming full circle John no
longer has any presence and he must
steal Holly back he becomes obsessed
with it closing the loop of the white
elephant gift exchange all in the lobby
of the Nakatomi Plaza ending the
Christmas elephant gift exchange because
let's be honest he killed all of the
other terrorists and all of the gifts
are his to steal anyway that's your
die-hard white elephant gift exchange
you're welcome now let me leave you with
one fact before I get you out of this
video the word Christmas is said 12
times from 7 different characters there
you have it diehard is the greatest
Christmas movie of all time if you don't
like it comment below yell at me tweet
at me I'm here to take it you can't
convince me otherwise ho ho ho now I
have a machine gun
you